європейська Солідарність однозначно
вважає що всі спрощені процедури всі
прозорості процедури отримання
гуманітарної допомоги і розподілу треба
підтримувати це давно уже на часі але
сьогодні говорячи про цей закон проєкт
який достатньо нормально випрацюваний я
би хотіла підняти інакше питання і
просила би уваги усіх депутатів а
особливо тих які мають стосунок де
запорізької Львівської Чернігівської
Київської областей де було викриті
Шалені випадки зловживання владою і
розкрадання гуманітарної допомоги на
складах які керувалися військовими
адміністраціями А я нагадаю що військові
адміністрації - це не місцеве
самоврядування а це є владна вертикаль і
зокрема призначає голів президент а
керує гуманітарну допомогу голова офісу
президента бо він є відповідальний за це
чим ми бачимо хоча би одну доведену до
пуття справу чи ми бачимо кримінальні
справи і відповідальність тих хто
причетний до розкрадання мільйонів
мільйонів на цій гуманітарці нічого а
деякі чудо з Запоріжжя ще й отримують
державні нагороди після того як викрито
їхню причетність до злодіянь але я
хотіла би також привернути увагу до
складу в селі Убині на Львівщині де в
курнику за допомогою військової
адміністрації як виглядає розкрадалася
не просто гуманітарка а розкрадалися
речі які були виготовлені на замовлення
Міністерства оборони навіть у 2023 році
тому мені би дуже хотілося щоб ви не
просто зараз говорили що Україна
молодець партнери чудові що помагають а
щоби правоохоронні органи нарешті
притягали до відповідальності своїх які
належать до влади а не переслідували
волонтерів кількість справ проти яких На
жаль зростає давайте працювати на армії
на Перемоги а не на вашій кишені